alors ils serviront que trois dates qui
raconte votre vie 1997
deuxième au tour de france 1998 est
accusé de dopage et exclu du tour ainsi
que tous les coureurs de l'équipe
festina et 2000 après avoir nié pendant
27 mois vous passer aux aveux
votre descente aux enfers votre mensonge
vaut aveu vous raconter tout ça dans un
livre qui est publié chez robert laffont
et qui s'appelle plus fort qu'avant vous
savez comment on fait les chars virenque
attention
il voulait pas lâcher le guidon mais il
est mis 27 mois pourra jouer en même
temps bien alors donc ce livre est écrit
en collaboration avec jean paul vespini
qui est journaliste à la provence
bon un petit peu parlé de vous ma peut
parler de votre vie richard virenque
[Applaudissements]
echard virenque vous êtes né au maroc
votre père travailler pour la société
kléber colombes vos parents avez une
ville à casablanca dans le quartier
français et vous partiez passer vos
week-ends à 50 km de là la plage de dao
mais il y avait trois tentes une tente
cuisine une tante chambre une tante
débarras et vous alliez pêcher les sols
avec le zodiac à marée basse
et puis votre famille a été obligé de
rentrer en france à cause d'un racisme
anti français vous dit que je devais à
l'école accompagnés vivre avec les
volets fermés à la maison les gens jeter
des pierres sur les volets ils ont tué
votre chien ils ont tué notre berger
allemand non à 78 les français ça
commence et que ce n'était pas bien vu
et ma mère avait envie de rentrer en
france
on est rentré dans le var le maroc reste
pour vous une sorte de paradis perdu
d'une certaine façon oui c'est les
plages soleil la chaleur est bon plein
de souvenirs de plage j'ai pu découvrir
et vous rentrez sans votre petit vélo
vert sur lequel vous aviez appris à
pédaler parce que ceux des lots irai pas
de place pour lui dans les valises
contenant tous les fils de téléphone
c'était on croit être fort et puis non
voilà et alors heureusement dans la vie
vers l'âge de 12 13 ans votre frère
lionel vous fait découvrir le cyclisme
et vous rentrez dans un vélo club
vous commencez à faire vos débuts de
cyclistes début amateurs donc on
commence à 14 ans et après on enchaîne
toutes les catégories et à partir de 17
ans j'ai commencé à avoir des capacités
pour penser à aller un peu plus loin
d'enlever ou mais ça marche très bien
parce que dès l'âge de 18 ans il ya un
tour régional vous remporté cinq étapes
sur six donc très rapidement vous
révéler être un très bon cycliste
ce succès c'est pour vous faire
pardonner vos échecs scolaires
oui c'est parce que je me suis un moment
je me suis un peu réfugier dans le vélo
parce que je sentais que c'était
peut-être là où j'avais un avenir et à
l'école je me sentais vraiment pas bien
j'étais plus là pour pour animer la
classe et pour être un peu le pitre que
pour faire j'irai apprendre à travailler
je me sentais mieux à l'extérieur qu'à
l'intérieur
ouais puis vous devancé l'appel pour le
service militaire et vous allez au
bataillon de joinville donc déjà de
sable et un niveau bien entendu et puis
c'est le début de votre carrière en 92 à
22 ans c'est votre premier tour de
france vous êtes maillot jaune pour la
deuxième étape est là toute la nuit vous
posez le maillot sur une sur une chaise
et toute la nuit vous regardez le
maillot
oui ben c'est un taux de la nuit
répondre
changer de couleur non mais c'est de
rentrer dans le tour de france en étant
néo professionnel et d'arrivée de gagner
le maillot jaune maillot le plus
convoité de prendre le maillot aussi à
pois le maillot vert si j'avais rafler
tous les maillots j'ai rentré dans une
intro en matière du tour par la grande
porte et ensuite eh ben ça a été géré
c'est monté crescendo et j'ai toujours
aimé le tour de france vous dites mon
premier tour de france j'avais accompli
à l'eau claire
j'ai fini 25e oui mais bon c c'est
prometteur quand on est jeune en avant
et véronique en prenant deux trois trucs
on veut finir premier en même temps oui
peut-être au 6 mai
j'avais une carrière qui s'ouvre et
novembre alors si lors de votre
troisième tour de france que vous êtes
confrontés au dopage pour la première
fois donc vous rentrez dans l'équipe
festina la fameuse équipe de bruno
roussel et devinez veux tu
et puis du fameux bernard cents le
docteur mabuse
alors là vous raconter dans votre
bouquin comment ça se passe d'ailleurs
vous dites ça se déroule comme une
visite médicale normal oui quoi à
l'époque il y avait les règles étaient
simples
il y avait des contrôles qui était
instaurée et il fallait pas dépasser
giresse à rester aux contrôles urinaires
ouais et donc il y avait beaucoup de
substance qui n'était pas retrouvée donc
on n'était pas dans les prises de sang
donc à l'époque j'avais la vie était
belle pour les contrôles donc
quand l affaire festina éclaté ben ça a
changé la donne et est-ce que vous avez
essayé le pot belge
oui qu'est-ce que c'est le pot belge
c'est un mélange un mélange de cocktail
qui vont à tous de dahouët un maillet
une sensation de dodo faurie et cheveux
qui pousse sur la tête ça peut marcher
en tous les cas à richard virenque vous
êtes le seul français à avoir revêtu
cinq fois le maillot à pois rouges du
meilleur grimpeur
ça fait rêver un meilleur grimpeur
[Rires]
et puis le 8 juillet 98 ville veut tu
est arrêté à la frontière franco-belge
donc avec sa voiture bourrée de dope on
voit pleurer devant les caméras de
france 2 vous partez en hélico avec
votre frère vous n'êtes ni 30 heures en
garde à vue et vous dites dans votre
livre le roi de la montagne se retrouve
au fond du trou
c'est un truc excusez moi et vous emmène
fait une fouille rectale quoi alors
richard les policiers vous disent les
autres ont avoué
pourquoi tu n'avoues pas vous refuser
parce que je savais que le moment
j'allais parler
jallet moto suspendre donc
celui qui parlait il était suspendu et
pratiquement comme j'avais jamais subi
de contrôle positif
ouais donc ébats de preuves en même
temps non alors là le public commence à
réaliser que donc t-il armstrong
finalement tous les cyclistes se sont
toujours dopés que robert chapatte le
savait et qui nous avait rien dit voilà
les médias vous tombe dessus
les guignols évidemment un à l'insu de
mon plein gré c'est quand même devenu un
classique maintenant comment à l'époque
vous regardiez les guignols non je suis
tombé sur quelques j'irai série où
quelques clips des guignols il y en a
quelques-uns qui m'ont qui m'ont choqué
qu'ils m'ont fait mal
ouais qui ont fait mal à mes proches et
il y en a quelques-uns qui m'ont fait
rire aussi
et là il ya un truc était
incompréhensible c'est qu'en 99 malgré
tout vous réintégrer le tour pour vice
de forme en leblanc vient vous serrer la
main mais pas devant les caméras enfin
tout le monde est un petit peu gêné vous
prenez le départ avec un garde du corps
à côté de vous offenser situation un
petit peu étrange et en 2000 vous avouez
vous dites oui c'est vrai j'ai pris des
produits dopants
j'avais pas le choix alors le président
du tribunal vous dis mais finalement
votre maillot à pois
vous l'avez arraché de le perron et vous
répondez cette phrase définitif si vous
croyez qu'il suffit de se mettre des
piqûres dans le cul pour avancer il a
été maire mais quand je me dis ça
suspendu neuf mois donc bo quoi pour le
canton on dépassait le seuil de 50 cl
avec un jour de
de vacances et moi comme j'ai avoué
donc c'est comme un cas positif donc on
a suspendu mais les coureurs qui avaient
été suspendues à l'époque avant moi pour
les mêmes faits donc les mes copains
festina qui avait avoué
il avait une suspension trois mois à
l'hiver sans compétition et trois mois
en saison en compétition est moins là
suspens quand on a mis la suspension je
me suis dit bon je vais prendre un peu
plus parce que j'ai j'ai un peu attendu
avant de parler et lime en 1009 points à
faire donc aujourd'hui c'est j'ai été le
courant le plus suspendu maintenant vous
êtes clean
oui vous roulez à l'eau claire l'a fait
vous avez plus jamais gagné si
maintenant des abonnements ou les autres
se dope
si vous dopez pas vous n'allez pas
gagner j'ai gagné une des plus belles
courses à rio en 2001 hc
vous avez rien pris ce jour-là un an
donc on peut faire du vélo sens des
français
et oui on gagne en coupe du monde la
plus plate devant les grands sprinteurs
j'ai fait 240 kilomètres d'échappée
ouais le vent de face avec jacky durand
et j'ai tenu tête au peloton je sais
c'est pour ça que l'équipe domo vous à
vous a gardé les richard virenque
si vous étiez sûr de gagner le tour de
france
en vous dopants mais sans être pris est
ce que vous le feriez saisir gagner le
tour de france en europe en salle après
oui
merci richard viron richard vous avez
vidéo vous avez eu débat on va faire une
interview à penda
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et non ce que tu fais c'est pitoyable
non c'est un mouvement la lutte est en
marche terry surveille internet tu vas
avoir des surprises
ouais donc géré en interne elle se
signale que les ardison est maintenant
richard virenque
que préférez vous en vous la gentillesse
là un bon thé qu'est-ce que vous ne
supportez pas en vous mais j'ai remarqué
trop positives comme garçons
je sors d'une mauvaise vanne ces
mauvaises bases qu'est ce que vous
préférez dans le cyclisme
j'ai mes pilules pour les bonnes vannes
à temps
[Musique]
je t'avais superman maintenant j'avoue
déchirait tout cela arrive
qu'est ce que vous préférez dans le
cyclisme richard d'être de monter des
cols et d'être en fourrage et en fin
d'année à tous les virages
qu'est-ce que vous haïssez dans le
cyclisme courir sous la pluie
ouais le plus grand moment de votre vie
c'était quand la naissance de mes
enfants
et le pire moment le pire moment c'est
'cependant cela faire j'irai le tout ce
que ça a pu causer en niveau familial ce
qui vous fait le plus marrer dans la vie
c'est quoi brosser les tout ce qui est
vidéo gag caméra cachée à une fenêtre
d'avis ou fema oui il est pas mauvais
merci bien
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas pour les chats qu'est ce qui
me fait le plus chier dans la vie du
chien dans la vie c
et la maladie la pauvreté les gens qui
sont vraiment dans la misère
votre plus gros coup de fric c'est quoi
c'est après le tour 97
donc si le contrat que j'ai signé avec
festina en 98 la plus grosse perte
six mois après votre plus belle histoire
d'amour
ben celle que j'ai en ce moment avec ma
femme c'est à dire toujours resté fanny
ça durera cette histoire vous l'avez
rencontré commencé avec norma ciel
oui
j'ai pris un jaune donne j'ai pris un
laxatif je crois bien et va plus moche
histoire d'amour j'en ai pas eu arrêt
non parce que vous avez des plus sexy en
vous les fesses je crois ça leur plaît
aux filles les garçons qui ont déjà tous
avaient volé les fesses si vous avez de
moins sexy on vous richard les marques
de bons arrêts on faisait la marque du
marcel non non non deux
dumas oui ah oui ah oui du cuissard
londres car et c'est pas terrible
vous préférez quoi dans le sexe l'acte
l'acte charnel
non mais dans l'acte charnel à
dans sa femme prend la pilule c'est
maintenant le plaisir est ce qui vous
dégoûte dans le sexe que ça jure que ça
dure jamais assez longtemps ah ouais
vous êtes allé chez qui la terre
précoces richards n'ont pourtant non
mais il est malgré tout malgré tout vous
aimeriez que ça dure encore plus chez
les capacités d'endurance mais toujours
on aimerait aller plus loin c'est qui
est des produits pour sa survie
besson
ce mini
avant
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu